oui
bonjour à tous comme vous le savez nous
vivons dans une société en pleine
mutation avec avec des réalités qu'on ne
peut plus ignorer et qui nous imposent
d'un péril impérativement changer
il ya bien sûr le réchauffement
climatique évidemment il y à la montée
des extrémismes il y à la raréfaction
des ressources et des matières premières
première il ya les inégalités il ya la
pollution des sols des océans bien sûr
de l'air mais aussi la fracture entre
politiques et citoyens le chômage
et puis la montée de la société
individualiste en aparté de thaler et
j'en passe dans ce contexte il ya ceux
qui voient le verre à moitié vide ce qui
se met en mode autruches qui attendent
que ça se passe qui font comme si de
rien n'était en attendant je pense de se
prendre le mur
et puis il y en a il y a ceux comme moi
qui voit le levier le verre à moitié
plein pour nous la crise est l'occasion
rêvée de passer à autre chose et de
changer notre modèle de société pour
nous ce n'est pas la fin du monde c'est
la fin d'un monde celui de
l'exploitation irresponsable des
matières premières et des ressources de
notre planète mais aussi des êtres
vivants qui vivent dessus afin
d'alimenter un modèle de croissance
infinie qui n'a plus aucun sens
aujourd'hui
pour nous il y a des tonnes de raison de
penser qu'on vit une époque formidable
et qu'on peut changer la donne en plus
dans un contexte actuel où les où les
événements tragiques récents montrent
qu'on est prêts à se mobiliser et de
s'unir pour construire ensemble un autre
monde
alors ma question c'est qu'est-ce qu'on
attend ce qu'il faut qu'on attende une
nouvelle catastrophe pour nous les
optimistes
c'est le moment de construire ensemble
une nouvelle histoire un nouveau récit
collectif et d'un collectif il ya une
somme d'individus et c'est le moment de
parler de moi quelques quelques minutes
dans mon enfance j'ai été profondément
marqué et influencé par des beaux récits
des belles histoires des épopées des
voyages et neigeux des de cesse
aujourd'hui de me demander comment je
peux le transposer dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui
vous allez peut-être rigoler mais j'ai
été présent financé par un dessin animé
qui s'appelle il était une fois la vie
avec un grand personnage avec une grande
barbe blanche qui vous explique comment
fonctionne le corps humain avec sa
brigade d'anticorps les méchants virus
également avec les petites plaquettes
alors moi je me dis ah quand il était
une fois la vie pour nous expliquer ce
monde qui change aujourd'hui j'ai aussi
rêvé devant ulysse 31 et son odyssée à
bord de son vaisseau 10 ha usse
aujourd'hui ce qui m'anime c'est de
participer à lancer une odyssée des
temps modernes qui nous mènent tous vers
la connaissance du monde qui nous
entoure et de ses enjeux
alors ça va être compliqué ça va être un
chemin parsemé d'embûches et d'obstacles
c'est pourquoi ça s'appelle une odyssée
mais en tout cas moi j'y crois
donc j'ai une partie de moi c'est
vraiment l'état représenté par cette
tête d'ulysse ensuite pour construire un
récit collectif ça nécessite de créer du
lien entre les gens moi je suis fils
unique donc de tout en fait j'ai eu
envie de créer du lien de lancer une
dynamique collective en plus pour
l'anecdote il se trouve que j'ai été
pendant quelques années postiers j'ai
travaillé pour cette vénérable maison
qui a justement été créé pour faciliter
les échanges entre les gens c'est
quelque chose qui m'a profondément
marqué ton que j'en fais une partie de
mon corps ensuite justement pour
raconter cette ce récit collectif il
faut jouer collectif
il faut jouer à la nantaise
on est à nantes ça fait référence à un
club de foot le fc nantes atlantique qui
était 8 fois champion de france deux
fois plus que le psg
et oui pourquoi mais pourquoi ça parce
qu'ils ont su miser sur le talent de la
jeunesse et de son jeu collectif bien
plus que sur le talent des envies du
individualités j'ai été formé au fc
nantes atlantique j'ai joué entre 11 ans
et 16 ans je sais ce que c'est que le
jeu à la nantaise et je pense avoir
beaucoup plus appris sur les terrains de
foot que à l'école voilà donc je leur
présentais comme une partie de de mon
corps donc vous l'avez compris j'ai un
but moi c'est d'aider à construire cette
nouvelle histoire collective des membres
des temps modernes
qui nous mène vers un monde nouveau et
rapidement mais comme pour toute
histoire il faut un contenu dans un
premier temps et sur ce point pas de
problème c'est l'abondance
il ya partout sur la planète des
initiatives qui montre que le changement
a déjà commencé je vous donne un exemple
je sais pas si vous connaissez le
voralberg en autriche
trois cent cinquante mille personnes
c'était il ya trente ans l'un des landes
les plus pauvres en autriche bien là
tout le monde est en train de se mettre
en mouvement et il vise l'autonomie
énergétique du territoire à 100% le plus
vite possible grâce à quoi grâce à une
gestion une exploitation intelligente
des ressources et des compétences de
leur territoire alors plus proche de
nous je vous donne un exemple à locminé
en bretagne quatre mille habitants
pareil sans projet de l'autonomie
énergétique du territoire
alors c est basée sur la valorisation
des matières organiques dans le but de
générer du biocarburant gnv de la
chaleur de l'électricité du fertilisant
dans un ou deux ans ils vont en avoir
quatre kilomètres carrés la zone
complètement décarbonés à 100%
indépendant des énergies fossiles
il s'y met tous et ils vont arriver à là
vous faites de ce passé pétrole
nucléaire peut-être bien plus vite que
ce qu'on nous dit pourquoi parce que il
s'y met tous ensemble
donc vous voyez bien là je vous ayez
raconter deux histoires thaler on en a
vu d'autres mais mais il ya quand même
des belles histoires à raconter autour
de ce type de projet qui préfigure
demain qu'il faut du coup aider à se
développer et justement qui pourrait les
aider
c'est là que j'en viens à ce qui
m'intéresse de partager avec vous bien
il faut une grande énergie et l'énergie
de la jeunesse est absolument
fondamentale pour moi la clé c'est de
remettre la jeunesse à commencer par
vous les étudiants au centre des enjeux
de la société pour construire le monde
de demain
moi c'est ma bataille de tous les jours
mon graal et comme vous l'avez compris
mon audi s'est alors ça a déjà commencé
je vous donne un exemple projet delta
green qui vise à faire sortir de terre
un projet autonome en énergie tout usage
et que ce soit carrément désaccordé du
réseau électrique fait depuis la rentrée
un acteur économique a décidé de
s'appuyer sur les étudiants sur leur
faculté de générer des bonnes idées pour
avancer quitte à remettre en question le
projet qu'avait imaginé l'architecte
donc là c'est 120 étudiants non
et issus de cinq écoles visitées design
polytech col du bois l'icam pas encore
centrale mais c'est ouvert et qui se
mobilisent dans le cadre dans le cadre
de leurs cours et c'est ça qui est
intéressant dans le cadre de leurs cours
sur des thèmes comme le stockage
d'énergie l'intégration des matériaux
composites et bio sourcés sur
l'autonomie en eau les usages du
bâtiment avec donc l'objectif de générer
des bonnes idées et là donc il ya
vraiment soutient à fond du porteur de
projet qui dit bah alesi est là la
semaine prochaine on va challenge et 30
étudiants de l'école du bois qui vont
essayer de proposer une alternative bois
béton alors qu'à la base d'architectes
qui l'a imaginé 100% béton on va voir ce
qui va en ressortir et on va voir si ça
va remettre en cause le projet deuxième
exemple intéressant dans le cadre d'une
opération qui a été lancé qui s'appelle
transition positive sur les agents les
enjeux de l'alimentation l'année
dernière une centaine d'étudiants en
communication sont penchés sur comment
on accélère le changement de
comportement au niveau 2 de la
production de la consommation de la
gestion des déchets dernière sortie 13
projets dont un sur les parts sur les
jardins partagés
c'est pas quelque chose de nouveau les
jardins partagés par contre il veut être
une idée peu nouvelles notamment au
niveau de la communication action à
proposer ils sont allés voir une école
primaire qui s'appelle l'école léon blum
pas loin de l'hôtel de ville
à nantes ils leur donneront leur
demandait de dessiner des dessins des
fruits et légumes qui voudrait d'un
jardin partagé
les enfants ont dessiné ils ont pris les
étudiants l'est les dessins sont allés
dans la cour de l'hôtel de ville ont mis
ça sur la pelouse on ont fait une
affiche un slogan on communiquait ses
des communicants sont même fait quelques
plateaux de télé locale et puis depuis
on en train de réfléchir à la mise en
oeuvre de ce jardin partagé
alors on va voir si ça se fait ou pas
mais en tout cas ce qui est intéressant
de voir c'est que ça fait avancer le
smilblick comme on dit et ensuite qui
sait jusqu'où ça arrivera et les jardins
partagés comme je vous le dis c'est pas
quelque chose de nouveau il ya des
associations qui bouge et qui font du
super boulot depuis trente ou quarante
ans mais par contre pour avancer il leur
manquait peut-être un peu de folie
peut-être une juste une idée
bah on va voir jusqu'où ça va est-ce que
ça ira juste
que à l'exemple de la ville de tonnes
morden qui est quinze mille habitants en
angleterre où les espaces publics ont
été complètement métamorphosé par les
habitants eux-mêmes en une multitude de
jardins potagers là en envoie devant la
la police nation dans un principe
d'entraidé de partage
ba aujourd'hui ils sont presque à
l'autosuffisance alimentaire
hyper intéressant de voir ça donc c'est
un peu ce genre de projet que nous
accompagnons dans le cadre de notre
association qui va voilà il ya le terme
odyssée qui revient open odyssey et
est-ce qu'on expérimente depuis trois
ans c'est de mobiliser l'intelligence
collective étudiante dans le cadre des
cours pour booster les projets qui font
sens pour le monde de demain
et ça marche en tout cas vu de notre
côté ça marche
alors pourquoi selon nous premièrement
parce qu'avec les écoles avec lesquels
on avance on est sur une pédagogie qui
est active puisque transmissibles a
parlé tout à l'heure de design thinking
complètement là dedans on est hélas
comme vous le voyez on se met plutôt aux
côtés des étudiants on est positif
hyper important on leur dit que tout est
possible que vous pouvez faire les
choses et on leur fait confiance et on
voit le verre à moitié plein à combien
de soutenance j'ai assisté ou les
enseignants pointent est toujours le mal
plutôt que le bien et puis ça marche
aussi parce qu'il faut leur laisser le
temps de s'y atteler changer le monde ça
prend du temps d'étudiant ça des courts
pendant la journée
ben je crois alors est-ce illusoire
penser qu'on peut utiliser le temps de
cours pour permettre à tous les
étudiants d'appliquer leurs compétences
sur des projets qui change le monde et
pas seulement à quelques promos ou
quelques groupes d'étudiants et pour ça
marche il faut qu'on arrête de parler au
nom de la jeunesse arrêtons de parler à
leur place les jeunes ceux ci les jeunes
cela mais qu'est ce que les jeunes
pensent vraiment donnons leur la parole
nous c'est ce qu'on fait c'est
absolument hallucinant ce qui est en
train de se passer
et au final ce que
vous propose c'est de là qu'est l'école
alors attention pas pour la faire
disparaître à quai dans le sens de faire
autrement faire plus avec moins de
moyens moins de ressources financières
mais plus de ressources en neurones
qu'est ce que les clés pour hacker
efficacement selon nous donc comme vous
les bus c'est donc dire aux étudiants
que tout est possible qu'on en parle
d'ailleurs de crise certes mais que
c'est une grande opportunité pour
changer le monde
c'est dire aussi aux étudiants qu'ils
ont des pouvoirs voir des super pouvoirs
de changer la donne
ils sont un peu les héros pour nous des
temps modernes qu'il faut absolument
écouter pour changer ils doivent nous
montrer la voie c'est aussi les faire
travailler sur des projets qui vont
produire les emplois de demain leur
emploi vos emplois c'est pour ça que ça
a du sens c'est que ça et ça avance
tout simplement c'est des fois organisé
des soutenances en présence des acteurs
concernés pas simplement devant un ou
deux profs
combien de rapports d'étudiants hyper
intéressants sont restés sur les
étagères ou dans les placards des écoles
alors qu'ils renferment peut-être des
idées pour créer de l'emploi
c'est ça qui me taraude finalement c'est
aussi croire dans le potentiel
d'innovation et de créativité des
étudiants qui est actuellement comme on
le disait tout à l'heure complètement
sous-exploité qu'est ce qu'on attend
là on est un anti aqua quarante mille
cinquante mille étudiants mais est ce
qu'il serait possible de les mobiliser
50 mille étudiants dans leur cadre de
leurs cours donc avec des notes c'est
important autour des enjeux de demain
les défis sont énormes a relevé on ne
peut plus attendre il faut passer à la
vitesse supérieure donc vous l'avez
maintenant compris et vous en êtes
convaincu j'en suis sûr il est vital de
davantage miser sur l'énergie la
jeunesse de toute façon on n'a pas le
choix
alors moi dans ce contexte là comme on
n'a pas le choix je dis je dis tapis
allons-y misons sur la jeunesse
je remercie mon ami eric grelet pour les
illustrations et les dessins et est ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec lui et ce
que avec moi vous avez envie de dire
tapis je vous remercie de votre
attention